Speaker 1: All right. Let's talk about CPAC,
Texas 2022, it seems like every three weeks at
CPAC. It's actually not. But it was this weekend,
the Conservative Political Action Conference.
Donald Trump spoke at the event. Donald Trump
brought up an anti-trans swimmer. Trump tried
to kiss the woman and she rejected him. This
is one of the absolute cringe iest moments of
the entire speech. Donald Trump calls swimmer
Riley Gaines up to the stage to have her say
some transphobic things. Transphobia was the
most reliable applause, generally generating
theme at CPAC when Trump tries to kiss her. She
flinches and she pulls away. It is absolutely
beyond parody. Let's take a look.
Speaker 3: Crazy. It was the largest
applause I've ever heard. Come on
up here. Look at this. Look at this.
Speaker 1: Trump going in for the kiss there
and Riley Gaines coming in out of nowhere and
completely rejecting Donald Trump. A very, very
bizarre moment. Then Donald Trump again spoke
about his former doctor, Ronny Jackson, now a
sort of COVID conspiracy, congressman. And Trump
waxed poetic about when Ronnie Jackson would look
at Trump's body and be just impressed with it.
Speaker 3: Ronnie Jackson, my doctor.
Unidentified: Where's. Where's Roy? Oh.
Speaker 3: He was the White House doctor. He
was a great doctor. You know, he was a admiral,
a doctor, and now he's a congressman. I said,
which is the best if you had your choice.
And he sort of indicated, doctor, because he loved
looking at my body. It was so strong and powerful.
But he said, I'm the healthiest president
that's ever lived. I was the healthiest. I said,
I like this guy to know who the hell
he is. At the time. I said, But I.
Speaker 1: So yeah, I mean, this
entire healthiest president thing,
it's so stupid first because Ronny Jackson
didn't examine every president like, you know,
it's totally conceivable that Teddy Roosevelt
was healthier than Trump. But also, Trump is very
clearly not healthier than the person he followed
Barack Obama. So it's just very, very strange
stuff. Trump then blamed high energy prices on
the Green New Deal, which he wants abolished.
The only problem is there is no Green New Deal.
Speaker 3: To bring down energy prices we have
to abolish. A Green New Deal. A fake? It's a fake.
Speaker 1: Yeah, it's fake that it exists because
there has been no new bill signed into law that
could even remotely be called the Green New Deal.
There are a few elements in what was signed the
day after this speech, the Inflation Reduction
Act, that overlap with some of the proposals in
the Green New Deal. But I guess a non-existent
bill is responsible for high gas prices around the
world. Donald Trump Then do you? I don't know if
you guys have ever heard the phrase it's a joke.
The phrase is I accidentally the whole thing. And
of course the joke is you accidentally what? The
whole thing. Like there's a missing word. Trump
does the exact same thing here saying two years
ago we had the greatest in our nation. Unclear if
it's another one of his famous neurological
glitches, if he lost his train of thought,
if the teleprompter glitched, who knows?
Speaker 3: Two years ago, we had the greatest.
In our nation.
Speaker 2: What on.
Speaker 3: Earth? We had something
that was so incredible. We had the
greatest people in our nation.
Speaker 1: There it is. A very
weird trump, even confused by the speech on the
prompter. Not a lot of applause there. However,
there was a lot of applause when Donald
Trump mentioned abolishing the Department
of Education. I would bet no one in the crowd has
any idea what the Department of Education does.
Speaker 3: Political material to America's
schoolchildren in any form whatsoever.
And if federal bureaucrats are going to push this
radicalism, we should abolish the Department of
Education.
Speaker 1:
Yeah. The crowd goes wild but has
absolutely no idea what's going on.
Remember when liberals were supposedly going
to put people in camps? Obama wanted to put
people in FEMA camps and globalist. Yeah,
you know, all that Alex Jones type stuff.
Trump repeats his plan for literally
moving homeless people forcibly into
tent camps in outskirts rural areas.
Speaker 3: All of a sudden, that'll stop
very quickly. The only way you're going to remove
the homeless encampments and reclaim our downtowns
is to open up large parcels, large tracts of
relatively inexpensive land on the outskirts
of the various cities, and bring in medical
professionals, psychiatrists, psychologists and
drug rehab specialists. And create. Ten cities.
You have to have a day of tents. Right now,
they're living in tents with holes in them. You
don't have time, right, to build buildings. You
can do that later, but you have to get the people
off of today. We have to bring back we have to
reclaim our cities. And now you'll have so there.
Speaker 1: It is officially saying we will put
them in a tent camp and that'll be it. Donald
Trump then apparently confused about the fact
that unemployment is literally at a 50 year
low and the latest jobs report saw twice
as many jobs as expected created. Donald
Trump saying the job situation is really.
Speaker 3: Bad in American history. That's
why we had the job numbers. And don't forget,
you have that good job numbers right now.
They're not counting all of the millions
of people that aren't working. If you looked
at the real numbers, that 3.5 would be double
that. Maybe some people say triple that, right?
Speaker 1: Of course, that's always been the case.
People who are not looking for work and are not
working are not part of the unemployment rate.
That was the case under Donald Trump when Donald
Trump bragged about the low unemployment rate.
These people are morons, but the bigger morons
are the people in the audience who fall for these
stupid talking points. This has always been the
case. Donald Trump then also said some friend of
his paid eight bucks a gallon for gas. Dubious
because Trump claims to have a friend. That's
really the part that's not believable.
Speaker 3: Have it now at $5, $6, $7.
A friend of mine from California called
me this morning. He just paid $8.55. He
told me. California. And you follow? Yeah.
Speaker 1: Now, the truth is, of course,
that gas prices have been declining dramatically.
Now, more than 20% have gone from over $5 a gallon
to $4 a gallon. 54 consecutive days of gas price
declines. And even if you look at California,
California certainly higher than
the rest of the country at 544 per
gallon. So continued lies from Donald Trump at
CPAC. Let's now go to our interviews at CPAC.